[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs a vite vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi 9
mai pour prendre un peu l'air et en
serveur puis sur le végétal l'arboretum
de versailles chèvreloup propose deux
nouveaux parcours
valades dans cette édition la
commanderie à elancourt organise une
après-midi insolite ce samedi 11 mai de
particuliers entreprises et seront
nombreux à vous présenter leurs
inventions
l'un d'entre eux sera avec nous en
plateau avec une responsable de
l'événement puis nous découvrirons le
padel à ne pas confondre avec le paddle
ou on est debout sur une planche de surf
ce sport de raquette est de plus en plus
d'adeptes nous avons assisté à un
tournoi à bois d'arcy l'arboretum de
versailles chèvreloup comporte 2500
espèces végétales pour le découvrir deux
nouveaux parcours nous avons enfilé nos
chaussures de randonnée pour vous les
présenter
avec ses 24 mille visiteurs en 2018
l'arboretum souhaite faire encore mieux
en 2019
et pour cela de nouveaux parcours ont
germé le premier qu'une véritable
randonnée de plus de 10 kilomètres de
long a sillonné en 4 5 heures ce
parcours permet de découvrir les
différentes ambiances au végétal et des
différents paysages et d'avoir un aperçu
des différentes collections qui sont
présentes dans l'arboretum et cela
débute fort avec la fameuse aller de
cèdre bleu qui prolonge les perspectives
à la française du parc de versailles
sont les foudres de lattes la fin pointe
est plate et à partir 1922 fait 800
mètres de longueur et a priori c'est la
plus longue allée de sa double du monde
six jardiniers travaillent à l'année
dans l'arboretum pour entretenir les dix
mille arbres
cette flore qui abrite également une
faune variée et riche
lors de la randonnée justement c'est
quelque chose que me mettre en avant
c'est la biodiversité naturelle et lors
de la promenade qui fait tout le tour de
la white homme vous verrez forcément
soin des oiseaux des faisans il ya
beaucoup de faisans ou bien des lièvres
ou bien des poules d'eau des canards
pour se rendre des pommiers ornementaux
au bois de l'ancienne pépinière un
chemin tracé par la tonte au milieu des
prairies et un système de balisage bien
connue des randonnées
les adeptes de la balade familiale aussi
ont leur nouveau parcours consacré aux
espèces d'ile-de-france temps a voulu
que ce soit accessible aux familles donc
aux enfants et aux adultes
alors les panneaux il ya des choses à
dire mais l'idée c'est que les parents
puissent lire les panneaux avec les
enfants pour leur présenter les
différentes essences d'arbres mais aussi
quelques concepts écologiques des
concepts écologiques comme cet arbre
mort véritable biotope pour des espèces
souvent menacés par la tendance à
nettoyer les sous-bois de ces arbres
dont la vie est terminée
une partie du tronc et même d'écouter
les visiteurs peuvent s'amuser à compter
les cernes et déterminer l'âge de ce
chêne
notre idée c'est de présenter la
biodiversité et de sensibiliser
sensibiliser le public à sa protection
et donc il n'y a pas que la collection
d'arbres qui est intéressant tâches
évolué il ya aussi l'idée de montrer
comment vivent les arbres et comment ils
sont associés dans la vie de la forêt
quarante six panneaux jonchent le
parcours ile de france 2 900 m de quoi
devenir incollable sur la vie végétale
une soirée courts métrages des
réalisateurs locaux c'est votre rendez
vous dans les salles par michael et demi
d'euros dans notre salle au cinéma le
grenier à sel
le vendredi 10 mai à 20h30 nous
accueillons des courts métrages locaux
des courts métrages qui ont été réalisés
par des saint quentinois des trappistes
et à un peu au zona dans les zones
alentours il y a
une sélection de films qui a été fait
appel à films qui a été fait par
l'association
jolie prof donc c'est un partenariat
entre la ville de trappes le cinéma
grenier à sel et l'association jolie
prod
les réalisateurs les équipes de films
seront présentes pour parler de leurs
films et vous présenter leur film
il y en a pour à peu près deux heures
donc ce sera ce vendredi 10 mai à 20h30
pour les autres courts métrages locaux
n'oubliez pas que le vendredi 24 mai à
18h30 il y aura les courts métrages
réalisés dans le cadre du partenariat
que nous avons avec le lycée de la
plaine au nord donc ce sont des lycéens
apprentis cinéastes qui viendront
présenter leurs films le vendredi 24 mai
à 18h30
à bientôt au cinéma le grenier à sel
[Musique]
saint germain en laye vous propose de
vous transformer en fils terre comme on
le dit dans sud ouest
une toute première édition de ces fêtes
lysienne pour fêter l'histoire commune
de saint germain en laye et
saint-jean-de-luz pelote basque banda
est encore toro de fuego tout comme dans
le pays basque
vous êtes d'ailleurs invités à vous
vêtir de rouge et noir comme le veut la
tradition
avec ce temps humide on peut voir sortir
les escargots c'est d'ailleurs la
spécificité de la ferme de fanon à
senlis son éleveur de gastéropodes se
fait un plaisir de partager avec vous
son métier lors de visites
vous pouvez réserver en groupe pour tout
connaître de l'héliciculture vous l'avez
aperçu dans votre rubrique patrimoine de
7,8 journal le musée du jouet de poissy
rouvre ses portes
ils nous diraient par le ministre de la
culture dans la semaine le public pourra
le découvrir dès ce samedi 11 mai et mes
enfants
connaissez-vous le padel un sport de
raquette venus d'espagne dont le nombre
de licenciés a exposé en france de 15
clubs en 2009 à 176 en 2019 dont six
dans les yvelines le week-end dernier un
tournoi était organisé à bois d'arcy 46
équipes se sont affrontées aurélie rond
nous a cherchés en savoir plus sur la
discipline auprès d'une coach venu de
nice on dit ça mélange de tennis et de
squash de tennis parce que coup droit
revers en joue en double et ce quoi je
passe qui est des murs mais après c'est
on va dire que là c'est beaucoup plus
facilement accessible et après son sport
qu'elle très social parce que c'est pas
un sport comme le tennis individuelles
comme le squash on joue toujours par
équipes
et comme on est sur une petite surface
on a quatre donc c'est très vivant on
peut voilà chambrer l'adversaire
un robot qui vous scannez vos
imprimantes trois dimensions un
réfrigérateur de jardin pour ses
livraisons alimentaires toutes ces
inventions vous pourrez les découvrir au
premier village des futurs insolite à la
commanderie ce samedi 11 mai avec nous
en plateau flora tout est responsable de
l'atelier des sciences à la commanderie
bonjour bonjour alors un village des
futurs insolite qu'est ce que c'est
exactement
alors donc pour la première fois à la
commanderie nous organisons donc le
village des futurs insolite
donc il réunit à la fois des
associations des start up des
particuliers des inventeurs bien sûr
mais également des artistes qui
présenteront des inventions aussi des
objets fabriqués
le but est de valoriser les talents la
créativité l'ingéniosité l'inventivité
de montrer qu'à tout âge et dans tous
les domaines on peut être acteurs de
l'innovation et des inventions donc pour
cela nous proposons à samedi prochain à
la commanderie
différentes animations donc il y aura
des stands avec des manipulations des
expériences des rencontres vraiment des
start up des associations et pour tous
les âges ça va des enfants jouent qu'une
conférence trois adultes voilà tout à
fait donc des trois ans vous pourrez
avec vos enfants manipuler des objets
pour inventer les objets du futur voir
l'habitat du futur avec le musée de la
ville mais également participer à des
ateliers autour de l'art domino donc des
cartes programmables avec planète
sciences
regardez des robots classé des atomes
vous pourrez également vraiment aller à
la rencontre d'inventeurs médaillés de
grand salon vous pourrez aussi piloté
une oeuvre par la pensée avec ma flow
est pas doué ou imaginer de transformer
votre salon en galerie d'art avec art ô
cher c'est à dire c'est très nouvelles
technologies mais pas tant que ça
finalement il ya vraiment de tout voilà
il y à vraiment de tout et on a aussi
ont réussi dans le bâtiment des garde
quelque chose plus autour des arts
vivants avec à la fois une installation
complètement farfelu donc du trio
électro toys troy qui détourne de
l'électroménager et des jouets pour
créer des instruments de musique et
faire de l'électro donc voilà ça c'est
complètement insolite et puis vous aurez
aussi dans ce bâtiment donc un spectacle
avec les itinéraires poétique histoire
diouf une conférence complètement
loufoque à partir de 8 ans un film des
années 30 les folles l'invention de
monsieur bricolo à partir de 6 ans et
pour finir la journée une une conférence
une mini-conférence pendant une heure
sur le tourisme spatial mode de tourisme
insolite on aura beaucoup de choses
aussi sur la mobilité avec des start up
du territoire par exemple quitte
camping-car modulable de noël ti la
station de trottinettes électriques
rechargeables dewitte roth mais
également à la présentation d'un projet
des étudiants de l'estaca donc hyperion
autour d'un mode de transport à base de
capsules l'atlantique en solitaire ou
parler de spectacle un peu loufoque
qu'est ce qui vous a pris à la
commanderie vous est venue l'idée
alors
c'est à la fois loufoque mais pas
seulement parce que nous allons
présenter à la fois des inventions qui
peuvent être utiles insolite farfelues
ou futuristes
le but était vraiment de montrer que
tout le monde peut être acteurs de
l'innovation
vous avez lancé un appel à projets dont
il ya quelques saint quentinois aussi
qu'ils vont présenter leurs créations
tout à fait donc en plus de start up du
territoire et d'associations du
territoire comme le fab lab également
qui présentera des objets fabriqués au
sein du fab lab par exemple une machine
de turing fabriqué par un adhérent du
fab lab
il y aura aussi des particuliers qui
présenteront plus tôt des médias des
trucs et astuces pour le quotidien vous
ment pour à l'époque tout ça ce samedi à
la commanderie le 11 mai de 14h à à 20
heures
merci de t'arrêter d'être venu sur le
plateau merci à vous et donc pour
retrouver toute la programmation c'est
sur le site internet de la commanderie
qui s'affiche en mettre votre écran
amateurs de course à pied et course
cycliste vous avez rendez-vous à
maurepas ce samedi 11 mai pour la
quatrième édition du run and bike une
course de 16 km par équipe de 2 cette
année une deuxième course invitant
parents des enfants à courir ensemble
est organisé dès 15 heures on casse la
démarche direction le stade de france
[Musique]
obtenez votre sélection pour entrer sur
la pelouse le stade de france propose un
parcours immersifs et interactifs pour
entrer dans la peau d'un joueur
professionnel paul bullock et de nos
confrères via grand paris a mouillé le
maillot
dans les vestiaires du stade de france
c'est l'agitation entre les maillots des
mbappé zidane lloris petits et grands
sont à la recherche d'un 10 pour
déchiffrer le code qui leur permettra au
final d'entrer sur le terrain cette
visite pas comme les autres
c'est l'avant match la nouveauté 2010
neuf du stade de france
c'est un jeu en immersion au stade de
france qui permet en fait de se mettre
dans la peau d'un
joueur de match en passant par les
vestiaires des arbitres par la salle de
presse vestiaires joueurs
après si tout se passe bien il ya même
un petit entraînement et éviter d'entrer
dans une présidentielle sachant qu'il ya
un peu des gens qui sont pas très
gentils qui veulent nous empêcher de
gagner du coup à part découvrir qui
comment pourquoi et se défendre contre
ses ennemis
l'enjeu est important battre l'équipe du
sc users qui tentera par tous les moyens
de barrer la route du fc mis sur eure
pour gagner il vous faudra aller dans
des lieux inédits du stade comme les
douilles des arbitres et déjoue les
pièges des adversaires le tout sous le
contrôle énergique de coaching
elle est bienveillante mais ne faut pas
saisie n'est pas faux quand même bossé
faut travailler correctement
voilà toujours avec le sourire avec
énergie moyens inédits et ludique de
faire découvrir le stade de france
avant-match tente de plaire à toutes les
générations
nostalgique de 98 ou jeunes sportifs
connectés car pour cette plongée
immersive votre smartphone sera un outil
essentiel pour avoir tous les indices
résultat une visite qui semble réussie
pour tout le monde c'était bien mais
le stade le stade il est grosse
impression en fait je m'attendais pas à
voir autant de choses et j'ai été un peu
surpris raison qu'on voit la tête du
vestiaire arrivé au milieu de ce stade
c'est assez magique et on a envie
évidemment les sportifs qui ont la
chance d'évoluer là dessus avant match
l'expérience immersive est attestée dès
maintenant et c'est la fin de votre site
et loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles et des sorties
m
[Musique]
oh